i love a game with some player choice
mass effect the witcher divinity you
name it if i have any say in the outcome
of the story
i'm in however over the many many years
i've noticed that a
similar pattern runs through all the
characters i play
i'm always the good guy i'm willing to
push the boundaries
a little bit if i think it's worth it in
the long run but i rarely go beyond that
that's how i played studio zam's
masterpiece disco elysium back in 2019.
sure my detective had a messy past
but i wanted the best for him to write
his wrongs and turn over a new leaf
so i ended up playing a straight edge
cop hell-bent on solving the case and
helping as many people as
possible when the credits rolled i felt
i had redeemed my washed up detective
it was great but i knew there was
another side of this game
beckoning me sweetly calling my name and
welcoming me into its warm embrace
telling me things like lick that licker
off the table punch this stupid kid
square in the jaw for the hell of it and
take
every single sleazy bribe brandish
before me with the release of disco
elysium final cut i decided to do
exactly that i set all my attributes to
one and set out on the saddest
most pathetic adventure of my
detective's lifetime
or at least the most pathetic adventure
he could remember
[Music]
disco elysium is unlike anything i've
ever played it's
an ambitious rpg that asks you to solve
a case to the best of your ability
throughout your 30-hour adventure you'll
spend a lot of time talking to folks
following up on leads rolling virtual
dice and probably recycling bottles
describing it to someone makes it sound
like an elaborate long-winded joke or a
pretentious art house game
and as someone who absolutely adores
this game i'd be the first to admit that
it's very much both these things
except both of these things are smashed
together in a way that just
works for every twisted locker room
style joke it masterfully prods at the
inner workings of the human condition in
a profound and unique way
it also lets you do every drug under the
sun and become a superstar cop which is
rad as hell not the drugs part the
superstar part
they say the world isn't ready for a
rock and roll cop
no one wants their state monopoly on
violence to be mixed with
celebrity worship they claim to know it
would be dangerous for detectives to
rise to the ranks of
demigods it would be insane they say
to all this you say [ __ ] off and die
in a cool voice so when i fired up disco
elysium the final cut i was curious to
see how much of that experience
translated to an absolute [ __ ] up of a
character turns out it's all still there
it's just funnier and like 10 times more
shocking seriously some things i don't
even want to show in this video
i think i died three times before i even
left the hostel you started i reached
for my tie hanging on the ceiling fan
and
died i looked at my reflection in the
mirror and died
i tried to run out the door without
paying and you guessed it i died
when you only have one endurance and one
more out point every conversation is a
matter of life or death
begging for money can even get you
killed if you aren't careful
the real kicker here is that when you
set all your stats to one you are
unsurprisingly bad at everything
this means that the odds are stacked
against you for nearly every single roll
check
on one hand this means you die a lot but
on the other hand it means you typically
see the worst possible outcome of most
checks
this felt wrong wrong like
touching your sister's breast for
instance when i tried to run away from
the manager at the hostel
if you fail you trip and injure yourself
if you only have one point in endurance
you just straight up
die sure this can be frustrating but i
also think it's funny as hell that my
story in this particular instance
ended so unceremoniously and abruptly
when i reloaded my save i decided
instead i was going to arrest the
manager for being a prick and he just
verbally eviscerated me for my terrible
judgment
oh so apparently i'm a [ __ ] now okay
i'll be the [ __ ] and you'll be the
broke cop who owes me money
and no one will arrest anyone because
that's insane
how's that my antics as a colossal [ __ ]
up spread like wildfire once i slithered
out of the hostel
i tried to examine the body out back but
every time i'd get close to it i'd vomit
finally i picked up some ammonia which
helps mask the scent of a rotting corpse
but it didn't help enough and i threw up
again i literally spent my entire day
chasing other leads because i couldn't
do basic police work i even tried to
give up on being a cop but kim
god bless his soul wouldn't let me give
up on myself that easily
get ahold of yourself i've seen strong
men
turn themselves inside out for hours you
are facing
tough austria alcohol withdrawal makes
it considerably harder
my abhorrent behavior extended far
beyond a bit of vomit and general
buffoonery one of the few checks i
actually succeeded without safe scumming
was punching kuno in his stupid face
i was absolutely shocked when i passed
that check and knocked him flat on his
ass
if you've never played disco elysium a
play disco elysium and
b the footage of a grown man punching a
kid may be a little off-putting but i
can assure you
kuno is more demon than child until you
know this game does what it does best
and shows you that kuno is a victim and
product of the crumbling infrastructure
and deep-rooted corruption that has
seeped into his family life
it's heavy incredibly well-written stuff
but anyway
kudo doesn't explain [ __ ] kudo just says
[ __ ]
the hardest thing about playing this way
though is letting your partner kim
kutsuragi down
every step of the way if you play disco
elysium straight edge then you know he's
your rock
he's patient reserved understanding and
dedicated he knows the world is a messy
place but it's clear he's trying to make
it just a little bit
better when you play as a cruel
insensitive [ __ ] he's
constantly giving you the benefit of the
doubt early on every time i do something
despicable my gut reaction was
ah man i hope kim takes this all right
kim's response to your shenanigans feels
even weightier when you play without any
skills because there aren't many
thoughts in your character's head
normally whichever stat you invest in
will manifest as a personality in your
head
my liege you know what this case calls
for
a power detective
slither up to her you silver tongued
fiend
show her what world-class perfidy looks
like
if you don't invest in any stats that
gray matter between your character's
ears starts to feel
pretty empty your detective has little
intuition he's incapable of thinking
logically
he has zero sympathy and so on in a
strange way disco elysia made me think
about stupidity
in a very different way any other good
news
he's saying he lost his budget he what
he lost his badge who lost his badge
dick mullen who do you think it's
officer dick mullen from the best
seller dick mullen and the lost identity
nick mullen is not your name in order to
win the corrupt cop bingo game i was
playing i also took
every single bribe i could it didn't
matter who it was
who saw or how much it was i dipped my
finger in
everyone's wallet oh by the way i heard
you got a rather rude reception from a
certain
lawrence gut some people have no manners
it pains me to say this should take care
of that nonsense
i rationalized it by becoming a
communist hobo superstar cop though so
you know i think i get points for that
the wealth distribution is unfair i had
no money and i was famous so i deserve
that money right
the best part is that i didn't even pay
for the damages to the hostel i caused
the night before
instead i bought very expensive sneakers
a boombox and big useless speakers
i found the boombox particularly useful
for this playstyle because when i
equipped it everyone could hear me
thumping mad beats
it's kind of like when you roll down the
windows and blast the music in your car
because you are so desperate for
attention that you'll take any kind of
attention at this point even if it means
you being an absolute nuisance
i'm definitely not talking about myself
here anyway i didn't only spend my money
on useless things
i also bought a lot of drugs over the
counter drugs under the counter drugs
it turns out in this video game drugs
can actually improve your stats for a
brief amount of time but they usually
come at a cost
as you can probably guess when you play
a character with absolutely no skill
whatsoever
that kind of thing comes in handy so i
indulged
you suck a manly dose of the extremely
chemical
smelling liquid into your mouth there
it seeps into your tongue when you
swallow it's already almost
all gone however because i only had one
health and one morale point to work with
i had
to keep some medicine on hand to quell
any cardiac arrest or mental breakdowns
believe me when i say there were many
his slug-like
lips move but all you hear is an
echo lost gun
the world is swallowed by a black hole
of fear
only two words escaped its gravitational
pull
lost and gone despite being an
untethered ass of a man i did
genuinely try to solve the case i spoke
to everyone
followed up every lead and did
eventually examine the body when the
game gave me a bonus to my endurance
because
i had been waiting long enough which to
be honest was a bit humiliating
nevertheless the case still moved
forward in the messiest possible way
no matter how badly i [ __ ] up i could
still pull myself together and tug on
another thread
chase down another lead or share a smoke
with kim on the balcony in the stillness
of the night and if that ain't a
metaphor for life i don't know what is
sure you can die in disco elysium but
like some of the greatest rpgs you can't
really fail
if something doesn't work you can try
something else and if that doesn't work
you can try something else and if that
doesn't work you guessed it you can just
kind of try something else and if all
else fails you can just safe scum your
way through checks which
doesn't really relate to this life in
any particular way at least not in any
way i can make sense of it
anyway i guess my point is is that you
should play disco elysium and you
shouldn't let life get you down
like my absolute tornado of a detective
sometimes we take the strangest paths to
get where we need to be
but that's the beauty of it hell if you
don't want to solve a murder case maybe
your true calling is to become
a disco superstar or overthrow the
establishment through philosophical
conversations about workers rights with
a potty-mouthed red-headed kid
and if that ain't a metaphor for twitter
i don't know what is
[Music]
also unlike my ass clown of a detective
don't do drugs be polite in the comments
and subscribe to gamespot
one two three
[Music]
forever
to be free
[Music]
forever